I wrote the first few drafts and I was
really happy with the script then we
started thinking who would play this
imaginary Hitler now this was about 2011
at the time you know to make a film like
this you know you needed a-listers you
needed big names to be able to sell
these films what then happened is I went
off and I made what we're doing the
Shadows hunt for the world of people and
Thor I made three other films and just
left that script on ice and by the time
I came back to it the whole cinematic
landscape had changed and you didn't
need a-listers to sell your film anymore
you actually just needed good films so
Searchlight picked up the script and
they said we want to make it under one
condition that you play Hitler there was
no intention of playing the the
character when I was writing it nine
years ago and then but then I made sort
of it sort of made sense to me that in
the end there this film you know at its
heart is um you know it's about this
relationship between these two kids you
know trying to like Foster some
understanding and and overcome this idea
of intolerance and hate and I feel like
if you had a massive celebrity playing
hit that would overshadow that
overshadow the importance and the power
of that story